we need to take responsibility for our
deficit and reform our government that's
how our people will prosper that's how
we'll win the future President Barack
Obama's 2012 budget plan and the likely
Republican response won't win the future
for at least three reasons
Obama proposes spending 3.7 trillion
dollars in 2012 and figures to trim the
deficit by 1.1 trillion dollars over the
next decade which is another way of
saying that the budget does nothing to
balance spending and revenue in fact it
adds about eight trillion dollars to the
national debt over the next decade
best-case scenario is the national debt
grows from sixty-two percent of GDP to
seventy-seven percent of gdp in 2021 and
there's absolutely no reason to believe
that in just two years Obama's deficit
projections have already had to be
massively revised his original estimates
were way off because he grounded them in
super optimistic revenue and economic
growth projections just like he's doing
now
there's a little reason to believe that
the republican counter proposal will be
any more substance prior to last fall's
election GOP leaders released their
pledge to america which was both vague
and uninspired showing only the
slightest difference in spending in the
present since winning a majority in the
House of Representatives the GOP is
dilly-dallied over cutting even 100
billion dollars out of 2011's 3.6
trillion dollar budget this is no way to
fix a bipartisan budget mess that was
many years in the making we're still it
looks as if it'll get much worse before
either Democrats or Republicans or move
to real action for reason TV I'm Nicolas
you